AND NOW TO CENTRE ICE.
EHLERS WITH IT.
HE HAD TROUBLE WITH IT.
PLAYED BACK NOW INTO THE JETS
ZONE AND NINE SHOTS ON GOAL FOR
ALL OF THE WINNIPEG FORWARDS
TONIGHT AS SUZUKI COULD NOT GET
IT TO THE NET.
BLOCKED, POOLMAN, AS THEY BATTLE
AND CAUFIELD PICKING IT UP IN
FRONT AND SHOOTS, SCORES!
SERIES WINNER, TYLER TOFFOLI AND
THE CANADIENS ARE THE KINGS OF
THE NORTH!
[ Horn ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Chris: HOW ABOUT THE KID, TWO
OVERTIME GOALS AND TWO OVERTIME
ASSISTS AND NOW THE BIGGEST GAME
THAT HE HAS BEEN INVOLVED WITH
AS A CANADIEN.
>> Craig: THE HANDSHAKES ALREADY
BETWEEN THE COACHES AND
CAUFIELD, SEARCHING HIM OUT,
THAT WAS A ROCKET OF A PASS,
CROSS-CREASE, INTO THE BACK OF F
THE NET AND CAREY PRICE WASN'T